so it's my honor tonight to introduce a
renowned environmental health expert and
distinguished epidemiologist whom you
might have heard interviewed yesterday
on wnyc's leonard lopate show or last
month on NPR's fresh air program as
Terry Gross Deborah Davis is director of
the world's first Center on
environmental oncology at the University
of Pittsburgh Cancer Institute and she's
internationally known for her work as a
researcher on the environmental causes
of breast cancer and chronic disease she
holds a PhD from the North Chicago and a
Masters of Public Health from the Johns
Hopkins School of Public Health from
1990 for 299 dr. Davis served as
president clinton's appointee to the
chemical safety and hazard Investigation
Board and as the senior advisor to the
assistant secretary for health in the
Department of Health and Human Services
she counseled leading officials in the
u.s. United Nations World Health
Organization and World Bank from 1983
293 dr. Davis was scholar-in-residence
and executive director of the board on
environmental studies and toxicology at
the US National Research Council of the
national academy of science she's
currently visiting professor in the
department of environmental and
occupational medicine at mount sinai
medical center here in new york and i
could go on and on but dr. Davis is also
as you're about to hear a highly
accomplished science writer she was the
National Book Award finalist for her
2002 publication when smoke ran like
water tales of environmental deception
and the battle against pollution and
she's authored more than 170
publications her new book the secret
history of the war on cancer published
last month has been widely praised in it
dr. Davis argues in a nutshell that the
appalling result of this country's
misguided 30-year war on cancer has been
more than 10 million preventable cancer
deaths one reviewer called the book grim
but fascinating reading and I can attest
to that as one of the books very
gripping but chilling chapters will
here in the next edition of the
Academy's member magazine so I want to
thank dr. Davis for joining us this
evening we want to give special thanks
to the Perseus Books group for offering
copies of her book for sale here this
evening your purchase will go to support
the Academy will have time for a short
QA after the lecture if you'd come to
the microphone to ask your question
since we're all being recorded and then
we'll have a reception in book signing
so please stay to join us for that but
welcome Deborah Davis good evening the
honor is mine let me assure you i'm
really delighted to be here and this
fabulous building and to see so many
dear old friends and some new ones as
well i'm going to talk with you this
evening about the secret history the war
on cancer and i have to tell you a
little bit about where i come from to
set the context for that i grew up in a
town called Donora Pennsylvania how many
of you've ever heard of Donora
Pennsylvania this is a very unusually
well informed group at least ten percent
well I want to show you what it looked
like this is an extraordinary image that
was taken 1910 and it shows this huge
mill which was a six storeys tall that
blocked out the river and you see this
little thing right here this was a
bucket for the blast furnace it was put
out back because a man had fallen in and
been incinerated and when that happened
and it did with some regularity they
would bury the bucket out back his
remains presumably inside and the molten
material as it hardened people came to
Donora because smoke meant jobs and
that's what they wanted in those days we
would go outside and play and if you
blew your nose it would be black nobody
thought much of it well I only learned
when I went away to school that
something unusual had happened in an
aura in one five day period 20 people
dropped dead in Donora Pennsylvania in
nine
48 I came home one day and I said to my
mother mom was there another town with
the same name as ours she got kind of
quiet why are you asking i said well i
read in a book at school the town called
Donora was polluted now pollution
sounded like a dirty thing so i thought
had to be someplace else she said well
you remember how we used to wash the
walls down about once a month I was tall
so I got to help early on said yeah
remember how we used to drive with the
headlights on to it the afternoon
because it's kind of dark often I said
yeah well she said I guess today they
would call that pollution but back then
it was just a living that's when I
realized that I came from in a somewhat
unusual place and I wrote about what it
was like you see here the hills opposite
the zinc plant the plume there the smoke
coming out of their shows you what it
was like on a typical day that's not
snow on those hills nothing grew much on
them sometimes the graves would wash out
of the ground and we learned to live and
play in an environment like that in fact
it was great for a tomboy because when
you played kick the stick he kicked the
stick there you could slide to first
second and third base because there
wasn't much grass under your feet and
when you went outside as a kid you got
what they call the Donora measles sort
of black [ __ ] stuff all over the place
men would go to work with two white
shirts if they had a white-collar job
and by noon they'd have to change to the
second shirt because the first one would
be soiled this is what Pittsburgh looked
like in nineteen forty at noon if you
look carefully here you can see it's
daytime right but this is how dark it
was and that's what people expected was
normal this was the sign of prosperity
Pittsburgh became a leader in cleaning
up the air and what happened in Donora
in 1948 ultimately led to the Clean Air
Act to a recognition that if a large
quantity of pollution could kill some
people it killed 20 people in five days
it raised the question
what does pollution do the rest of us in
a short period of time so coming from
Donora I had a special appreciation
shall we say of the long-term
consequences of pollution for health and
I learned as well that the town I came
from had been infamous in environmental
history I came from a famous place I
guess famous in the same way as Jack the
Ripper or the Son of Sam so it wasn't
surprising that nobody ever talked about
it there well I've been now working as a
cancer epidemiologist with some of the
best and brightest people in the field
for more than 20 years and I began to
try to write this book about 20 years
ago and I went to see my boss at the
time Frank press a very smart man who
had been President Jimmy Carter's
science advisor who was the head of the
National Academies of Sciences dr. press
had been very supportive of my career he
had encouraged me to publish analyses
some of which I published with the new
york academy of sciences some of which i
published in the lancet and science and
jama showing that there was an increase
in cancer that could not be explained by
smoking or aging alone and because of
dr. presses support I was able to do
that work so i was pretty excited when i
went in to see him one day and I said
dr. press I have an offer to write a
book as a kind of catchy title cancer
Wars I remember Star Wars I think it's
still with us cancer wards was a bit of
a spoof on Star Wars and I'd been
offered a very handsome advance to write
a book critical of the cancer enterprise
for its failure to address the causes of
cancer dr. press listened and then he
said it had better be a good book I said
well of course it's going to be a good
book I wouldn't try to write it
otherwise he said it had better be a
really good book I didn't understand
what he was getting at I said I don't
understand he said well I'm not telling
you what to do you're free to do
whatever you want but if you write a
book critical to the cancer enterprise
given what's going on
right now you won't be able to work here
when you finish and you know some people
have read that passage in my book and
and interpreted to mean that he was
telling me all never eat lunch in this
town again or some variation on that
well in fact he was giving me good
advice because it turned out that when I
was thinking about writing this book
cancer Wars it was the dawn of what we
now think of as the Reagan Revolution
and the last thing anybody wanted to
hear about then was that there was an
increased role for government and the
private sector to clean up their act
this was the days when people thought
that the last thing the government
needed to do was to regulate anything
and as a consequence during the Reagan
Revolution much of the effort to control
the environment and in fact to protect
workers from hazards in the environment
was really undermined by things that
happened at that time we're still
recovering from some of it so I listened
to dr. press I didn't write the book
then but I am writing it now and I'm now
from Pittsburgh and I'm now part of a
major corporation that would not have
happened if I'd written the book at the
time I first was thinking about it the
lessons of the book are very simple if
you want the future to be different from
the past you have to study the past so
the book is in part an exegesis of the
history of science and medicine it tells
stories of things that many scientists
are surprised to hear about and I
believe it shows that for a long time in
much of the war on cancer we've been
fighting the wrong war against the wrong
enemies with the wrong weapons now let
me be clear we've had tremendous
progress in the war on cancer there are
10 million cancer survivors today that's
a credit to what oncology has been able
to do unfortunately 1 million of them
are under age 40 and no matter how
efficient we may get at finding and
treating cancer and we're getting better
at it if we don't reduce the demand for
treatment we will never succeed in
really reducing the toll of cancer
on our lives I talk about myself as a
cancer orphan and technically that's not
correct because I didn't lose my parents
until I was an adult but when my father
in his mid-fifties announced he'd lived
a long life when he faced a diagnosis of
multi myeloma that didn't seem fair at
all and I lost both of my parents to the
disease at younger ages than I think I
should have in fact this was my father
at age two seated there in the family
dry cleaning shop the factory that
cleaned the clothes was in the basement
there was a huge explosion there in 1923
my grandparents were using benzene to
clean the clothes and benzene was known
to cause cancer in the 1920s and I have
records of that that I've put on the
website of the book which you can find
as well detailed archival information
showing that scientists understood the
dangers of benzene benzene is a
remarkable solvent it slices right
through grease it slices right through
skin and bone and that's one of the
reasons why it's associated with an
increase in a number of cancers
including the one that my father ended
up developing when he was in his mid-50s
now those of you who know me well
probably won't be surprised to learn
that I am the daughter of a drill
sergeant my father actually was very
patriotic and he became a brigadier
general retired from many years of
service proud service to this nation
when he was diagnosed with multiple
myeloma we had no way to know what the
causes were but we do know there were
many among them could have been the fact
that he survived this explosion because
my grandmother was able to get him out
of that fire and he was exposed at a
very young age to hyatt levels of
benzene and other things but he also
worked as a teenager in the mills like a
lot of people did in Donora and
Monongahela he was very proud to have a
mill job and he
job as a chemist at age 16 and he was a
machinist by the time he was 18 pretty
heady stuff for a young man from such a
small town he went on to become a very
successful businessman but always worked
with machines and even when he was
diagnosed with cancer he still had a
lathe in his basement and still worked
with cutting oils and solvents and
things to make candlesticks and things
that we use to light the Shabbat candles
which I would be doing tonight if I were
not here with you all so my father was
quite a character my mother was an equal
match she was a remarkable survivor of
many things she survived three bypass
surgeries three major back surgeries and
two angiograms and one of the things
that I know now is that her survival of
all of that surgery came with a certain
price because in the days that she had
those surgeries almost 30 years ago the
amounts of radiation that patients
received as they were routinely
monitored through that surgery was
sufficient to cause cancer and we now
know that radiation can cause cancer
particularly diagnostic radiation which
may be medically appropriate and can
save lives at times can lead to an
increased risk of cancer later on now I
want to give you some of the evidence
about why we know the environment is so
important these are the chromosomal
bands of identical twins as you all know
identical twins start out from one egg
splits in two and they are as close to a
clone as we have in human nature at age
three these chromosome bands of 13 12
and 17 here from an article in the
National Academy of Sciences proceedings
by Mario fraga and colleagues they have
identical patterns pretty much of what's
turned on and off and you can see these
patterns here just in the parallel
images but look at what happens to the
chromosome bands by the time they are
age 50
d if you look at the bottom and top two
they don't even look like they're
related to one another look very
carefully you might imagine they word
from two unrelated people all together
at age three they are close to identical
as which is not surprising this is
telling us something very important
genes are important determinants of
cancer but it's the interaction of the
genes and the environment that
determines whether or not cancer is
going to develop and lots of things
happen even in the case of identical
twins to influence how their genes
change how the chromosomes are altered
over time what tumor suppressor genes
and genes are turned on or off all of
those things reflect the complex factors
in the environment which were exposed I
found this an amazing image because it
was one of the first truly international
scientific images this is the hand of
Roberto Renkin the wife of vilhelm
Conrad Renkin the man who discovered
x-rays she never again had another x-ray
she called them a death ray I think it
may have something to do with the fact
that they never had children that his
lab was right over their bedroom and he
worked sometimes through the night
experimenting with these x-rays when he
took this picture he knew he had
something extraordinary and he mailed it
to several colleagues and to newspapers
and within a month it was on the front
page of newspapers in Paris and Tokyo
and London and people were holding x-ray
parties they were having the machines
out within a few years of this taking
pictures of one another watching their
skeletons move how many of you remember
those x-rays that used to take of your
feet to fit your shoes when you were a
child oh I love doing that people had no
idea in the beginning how harmful x rays
could be or at least the public didn't
understand that
but Thomas Edison did his assistant
Clarence daily as far as I could tell
was one of the first people to die of
radiation poisoning first he lost his
arms burns never healed and eventually
he lost his life in 1904 Edison never
had another x-ray again in his own life
Madame Curie is well known for her
phenomenal work in identifying polonium
a substance that was named for her
native country of poland died of
leukemia her notebooks were too hot to
handle that's how much radiation they
had received so the dangers of radiation
were understood and yet somehow that
information didn't get to the rest of
the world in a way to be as effective at
limiting exposures I was shocked as I
was doing the research for this book to
find this volume published in 1936 in
brussels by the second international
congress of scientific and social
campaign against cancer 1936 the world's
leading scientists came by boat and
train to brussels where they met for two
weeks and reviewed all the evidence then
known about things that caused cancer
and the kind of evidence that they
looked at then was not limited to what
we call today public health phenomena of
humans in populations with large numbers
and statistical significance the
evidence of what caused cancer in the
1930s was considered a combination of
experimental findings and animals
clinical case reports well researched
and documented of exposures and effects
and some statistical analyses of
patterns of disease in people with
unusual exposures these are the things
known in the 1930s to cause cancer
diethylstilbestrol was actually
synthesized back then and it was used
very early on to fatten
and pigs in fact the Germans used
diethylstilbestrol to fatten their
animals and they noticed that the boys
who were making it were getting breasts
and complaining because their breasts
hurt so they decided that they'd only
have girls make it because why would a
girl object to having slightly larger
breasts they also understood the dangers
of solar radiation cult ours benzene and
uranium mining and look at this
extraordinary drawing from 1936 it could
be from something someone would have
done yesterday these are
radiation-induced tumors from sunlight
from the work of on hell honorary o rofo
in Argentina he headed up research on
the dangers of tobacco in the 1930s as
we know from the work of Allen Brandt on
the cigarette century the dangers of
tobacco were not suddenly become
apparent in 1960s they were known for
most of the 20th century if not even
earlier and yet it was the development
of the field of Epidemiology as a
discipline that had a paradoxical effect
on what was considered evidence and
proof of harm it's quite an interesting
thing to think about proof of harm has
been defined particularly by this
administration as enough sick or dead
bodies amassed in a given point in time
in a certain location with confirmed
exposures that we can conclude that
their illness was caused by a particular
exposure that's a pretty unusual way to
think of it what that means though is
that if you have evidence like this
where every animal exposed to sunlight
develops a tumor you don't use that
evidence to identify something that's a
cancer risk for humans the field of
Epidemiology I discuss in my book really
grows up as a discipline around the
issue of workplace dangers and tobacco
and it can't completely be separated
from the economic forces that gave birth
to it
and for those who are interested I hope
you'll read more about it in my book
it's a very very fine dance that one
does with with respect to what is
considered evidence the epistemology of
Public Health can't really be separated
very easily from the economic
environment in which issues emerge
here's another example of that this man
with the lighted match striking his pipe
Bowl was the first director of the
American Cancer Society a position he
held until nineteen fifty four he was a
brilliant geneticist he headed the
Jackson labs he worked from the time he
was a child breeding mice he was an
ardent advocate of eugenics as were many
many American leaders in 1954 he got
kicked out really of the American Cancer
Society not because he advocated smoking
that was a position the American Cancer
Society was very comfortable with for
some time he left the American Cancer
Society in 1954 to become the leader of
the scientific advisory board of the
tobacco industry research council and in
case you think this is just an unusual
historic event let me tell you about
something that's happening right now in
the state of Pennsylvania that I'm
ashamed of frankly as a taxpayer behind
closed doors the Pennsylvania Senate is
considering whether to weaken the
legislation that has been passed to ban
smoking in public places now New York
has done this way in advance under
Republican leadership that should get a
lot of credit for having understood the
dangers of smoking in public places
Pennsylvania is still a little backwater
one of the reasons we are is that a
fellow who worked for the American
Cancer Society of Pennsylvania resigned
his job for the American Cancer Society
in 1993 to go to work for the tobacco
industry in Pennsylvania in 1993 pusa
shawls and what he did for the tobacco
industry then and what he's doing right
now is
lobbying for the casino industry arguing
that you have to have smoking in casinos
so you better give some exemptions to
controlling smoking in public places in
my book I make it clear that this
formula of trying to find the weak link
in the argument and going behind the
scenes and working with politicians to
make it easy for people to continue to
pollute whether it's tobacco or asbestos
is a pattern that continues even to this
day when the national cancer act is
signed in 1971 there's some really funny
things that went on then and there's
transcripts of debates between Ted
Kennedy and Richard Nixon about which
one of them hated cancer more yet to
remember the United States was not in a
strong position it was losing a war a
real one in Southeast Asia President
Nixon was told that they would actually
have cured cancer by the centennial can
you imagine not too many scientists
believe that I was honored to have spent
some time with Joshua letter Berg the
this week and he told me he never
thought that they're the cure for cancer
was going to be an easy thing to find
and he always recognized how important
it was to pay attention to the things
causing cancer but think about it it's
1971 it's seven years after the u.s.
surgeon general has declared that
tobacco is a cause of cancer it's nine
years after the royal college of
physicians in England has said the same
thing and it's more than 20 years since
seven different scientific studies have
all said tobacco is causing cancer and
other health problems and the president
says let's fight the disease and is
silent about tobacco and silent about
asbestos and silent about benzene or
radiation all of which were known to
cause cancer back then that is why I say
in my book the secret history of the war
on cancer for much of the war we've been
fighting the wrong enemies we need to
focus our attention upstream at the
things that cause cancer rather than
just improving our efficiency to find
the disease and treat it as i said the
good news is we've gotten better at
doing this that's why I think breast
cancer and prostate cancer colorectal
cancer are declining that's a good thing
but we need to figure out how to prevent
cancer from happening in the first place
and that's going to take paying more
attention to the things that we know
cause it here was a cartoon by her block
in 1977 that I think expresses the
realization that dr. letter Berg and
others had if you could find a cure for
cancer it'd be a lot easier than
prevention don't you think there were
even people in the asbestos industry
that tried to give workers a vitamin
pill with their paychecks because after
all if you could cure cancer then it
might not be so bad look none of us
would not want none of us is not
interested in curing cancer but we have
to understand that the best way not to
die of the disease is to keep yourself
from getting it in the first place and
paying more attention to the things in
food and drugs is going to be an
important thing to do although again
most recently in this administration
it's been claimed that they don't really
need any more money and they don't
really need any more inspectors of food
and they don't really need any more
inspectors of lead and children's toys I
think that those are positions that
Americans may not all agree with I know
I don't but in understanding why tobacco
was such a tough habit to kick you have
to realize that the addiction to tobacco
wasn't just a physical addiction it was
an economic addiction the country
dependent on tobacco revenues and
doctors were among the biggest users of
tobacco for a long time so it was not
that hard to get them involved the
American Medical Association worked for
the tobacco
industry well into the 1970s into the
1970s and they issued a report in 1979
that's quite extraordinary that I also
have on the website for the book saying
in 1979 well it looks like tobacco is
bad for the lungs but we're still not
sure about lung cancer it's kind of
amazing to realize how long and firm the
grip was on the nation's leading
thinkers about tobacco and the reason I
talk about tobacco is because that is
the model that is still operating today
for other hazards which I will come to
in a moment one story that has not been
widely told is that the United States
government spent more than 30 million
dollars to make a safe cigarette your
taxpayer money went to make a safe
cigarette the head of the National
Cancer Institute throughout the 1960s
was a four pack a day smoker it's kind
of hard to imagine how you could smoke
four packs a day actually I've
interviewed some people who knew dr.
Endicott and they said he was kind of
interesting to watch when he would do
any went to the restroom because he
always would have one cigarette waiting
almost from the time he was awake Ernst
winter who did brilliant work on the
dangers of tobacco was an advocate of
making a safe cigarette and these
fellows really had it wrong as we know
now but it took a long time for that to
become apparent hope is the most
important drug we can give cancer
patients but look at this headline from
Life magazine 1958 fresh hope on cancer
the man who sent me this was an
undertaker the woman on the cover was
his aunt she died of metastatic cervix
cancer cervix cancer was a death
sentence in 1958 for many women in my
book I disclosed that it did not need to
be a death sentence then because in fact
scientists knew that the pap smear could
find cells that were going to become
malignant early and allow doctors to
remove them but the pap smear was not
put into use it was first invented in
the 1920s by dr. Papanicolaou it was
proven to save lives in a clinical trial
in 1942 but it was not put into
widespread use until the 1950s and look
at what happened as a result in each one
of these areas you see the amount of
cervix cancer at the time before the pap
smear was put into use indicated here
and then the drop in service cancer
which drops by at least fifty percent
after the pap smear is being used what
was the fight about doctors feared that
if you did pap smears you would
undermine the private practice of
medicine it would lead to socialism it
would lead to manage to care and there
was a ferocious fight that went on
within the American Cancer Society until
Charlie Cameron the scientific director
said these lives are on my conscience
you can't withhold this test any longer
we know it's going to save women's lives
indeed it did save lives and it still
does but look what happened in England
and Scotland they did not implement pap
testing until 1988 1988 and you can see
that they're the only two modern nations
where incidents of cervix cancer did not
fall rather amazing now I'm going to
show you a little bit of data from
further analyses that we are doing today
with colleagues at the National
Institutes of Environmental Health
Sciences and our Center for
Environmental oncology at the University
of Pittsburgh and I refer to this in the
book because cancer statistics are
really complicated but just because
something's complicated doesn't mean it
can't be understood at all and what
we've done is to try to sort out what is
the change in cancer
taking out smoking and taking out
screening related cancers we've done
analyses and what I'm going to show you
here is this first number here is those
rough reflects the amount of cancer in
people born in 1893 and the amount of
cancer in that group and successive
birth cohorts born in 1933 1943 etc and
you see this remarkable decline in
smoking related cancers in men this is
the good news of cancer I believe it
could have happened a lot sooner if we'd
acted on what we knew about tobacco but
look at cancers not related to smoking
and this excludes prostate cancer which
we think a lot of that increase in that
is due to screening you see here a
continuing increase this is showing you
that there's one point six to one point
eight fold increased amount of cancer
not related to smoking or screening in
men in the United States for women
smoking related cancers have continued
to increase and you see that here breast
cancer is still higher for women born in
the 1960s and 70s than it was for their
grandmothers and cancers not related to
screening or smoking are also increased
in women now these are patterns of
disease in time and space they can't
tell you what the causes are but when
something changes relatively rapidly in
a short period of time you have to ask
what's going on in the world around us
to account for it and in my book I
discuss how we know that there are
environmental factors that we can do
better with most of you may think that
we found asbestos we haven't there's a
bill sitting in Congress right now and
again backdoor deals are being cut to
weaken it there's a bill to ban asbestos
EPA tried to ban asbestos and it was
thrown out by the courts the Congress
has tried to ban asbestos this year and
their efforts to weaken that approach
right now the United States
and Canada standalone in the modern
world from not having band asbestos
Canada is exporting as best as to India
as I speak and in India young girls and
boys are working with it and we know
what the consequences will be in the
book I show the images of what happens
to people who sometimes do nothing more
than comb the hair for 20 years of
people who are exposed to asbestos
Christy Todd Whitman the EPA
Administrator tried to launch a national
campaign to warn 35 million Americans
that there's asbestos in their attics
now in insulation in the form of zone o
light contaminated with tremolite from
Libby Montana a town a beautiful town
now also famous like Donora for
environmental infamy massive
contamination of Libby Montana has been
well documented pulitzer prizes have
been won by the reporters who've
confirmed this and yet the problem goes
on when Christy Todd Whitman tried to
launch this national campaign the Office
of Management and Budget refused to let
her do so if you know enough to look at
the EPA website today you can find
information about this problem but you
have to know how to look you have to ask
and a Chinese proverb says a way of
looking is a way of not looking and if
you don't allow people to look if you
don't set a public discussion and
information there's no possibility for
learning about these hazards and this is
a fixable hazard that does require
professional attention to deal with it
not all asbestos should be removed
sometimes it should be left alone but
asbestos in attic insulation of the sort
I'm talking about here is precisely the
kind that does release millions of
particles into the air and we're young
homeowners might go in to fix a wiring
problem in their attic and be exposed to
something that 30 or 40 years later
could cause them to develop a crippling
lethal lung
disease and my book I talk about the
fact the mesothelioma which is a
suffocating tumor of the lung that
killed Stephen Jay Gould mesothelioma
today occurs in people who've never had
any history of working with his bestest
1 in 3 people who develop mesothelioma
in many countries today have never
worked with his bestest well guess what
was in Kent Filter Cigarettes micra
night Chris satellite asbestos was the
filter for Kent cigarettes we had a lot
of interesting uses for his bestest that
we only are now fully appreciating and
that's one of the reasons I wrote my
book now we're often missing information
i want to show you examples of why we're
missing information some people say
what's the proof what's the beef why are
you worrying about silly little risks
like this after all you can't show me
any people that ever really have been
harmed by the environment well you know
what they're right it's hard to show
environmental harm life is a mixture and
the real environment that we live in is
complicated but here's an example of a
town that was so polluted the citizens
were able to get a lawyer even though
they were poor and black in Louisiana
and go to the factory and argue that the
levels of pollution in their backyards
were so high that they ought to be
compensated well they were they were
paid to move and this is what the town
looks like today it's gone there is no
town there are no data the absence of
evidence of harm here should not be
misconstrued as proof that there is no
harm rather it's a reflection of the
complex political and economic realities
in which we live here's another town
that I visited this is all that's left
of moskva Louisiana the painted names on
these placards all of them can't be read
all of them died in Mossville people
lived there for
five generations hunting and fishing and
living off the land the beautiful bayous
of Louisiana that I described in the
book amazing areas but the people of
mossville they got used to some unusual
things called sheltering in place
there'd be huge explosions and they'd be
told to stay in their homes and close
the windows one woman i interviewed told
me she saw swamp devils i said and i
don't i don't want to be disrespectful
here but you saw swamp devils she said
look when you're a nine-year-old girl
running for your life out of your home
in your bed clothes through the swamp
and there's water moccasins and
alligators out there you bet you they're
swamped Devils out there well these
people got together and their town was
moved as well the CDC actually has done
a study of the blood of the ones who are
still alive and they've actually found
some very high levels of dioxin there
but again it's not proof of anything
because we don't have an arjun of
population to have a statistically
significant result to show an effect and
again the absence of evidence in these
situations should not be misinterpreted
as proof that there isn't a problem
here's another one where the only thing
left in the town of smelter town is the
cemetery i visited here if it wasn't a
cemetery it would be a hazardous waste
site the levels of metals in the ground
are so high for more than a century
toxic dusts from its arcos idled smelter
in the town named smelter town went
across the canals the Rio Grande is
really a great big ditch at that point
concrete and very seldom has any water
in it much of the year according to a
memo released recently this melter was
conducting sham recycling the memo the
author of the memo is the US Department
of Justice
according to the US Department of
Justice the Asarco smelter was
responsible of sham recycling they would
take industrial waste from all over the
country and burn them claiming to be
recycling them but it wasn't really
recycling and as a result the levels of
pollution that went up into the plume
and spread around the area were quite
quite high this is another example of
the sorts of problems dead men don't
tell tales but the graves in those
cemeteries are pretty interesting a lot
of them are children they were found to
have very high levels of lead in these
children in the 1970s and I explained
that I studied this problem in 1980 and
I thought it was a problem of the past
when I studied it then for the
Congressional Research Service the
Environmental Law Institute where I was
scientific director did a study in 1980
I was astonished to go back there after
i wrote my other book and to find that
the problems of Asarco were not over
they just been transformed and now the
company is claiming they want to restart
this 150 year old smelter because if
they claim they want to restart it they
can avoid having to clean it up this is
one of those graves I mentioned a
two-year-old two years and four months
these are the graves of the poor that
soil is blackened with lead now I want
to return to a modern problem i alluded
to it when i talked about my mother's
experience with diagnostic radiation the
American College of Radiology just this
year has issued a white paper on
radiation dose in medicine many of you
who are interested in radiation physics
may be aware that we don't have a
standard way of calculating radiation
dose right now for CT scans but the
white paper from the American College
warns that the current use of medical
diagnostic radiation in the u.s. today
is about equivalent to the worldwide
releases of the catastrophe of Chernobyl
which was more than 400 hiroshima's the
Chernobyl releases were multiple
releases over a long period of time and
the American College of Radiology is
calling for reducing the use of
unnecessary diagnostic radiation here's
a calculation based on data from the
National Cancer Institute of the amount
of chest x-ray equivalents involved in
pediatric CT scans of the head of babies
if it's unadjusted for the for the size
of the head you can get between 400 to
6000 chest x-ray equivalents now you all
understand that a CT scan is not one
x-ray it's dozens to hundreds and in the
pediatric world the repeated use of CT
scans of the abdomen in the head is
something that really does need to be
controlled and the pediatric community
is aware of this that is the
radiologists are aware of it we at the
University of Pittsburgh are working
with leaders in the American College of
Radiology now to bring more public
awareness to this on the part of
physicians who run the emergency rooms
now let me be very clear if your child
is unconscious and has a head bleed you
will may need a CT scan for your child
but these CT scans are being used for
many conditions where it's not an
emergency and not considered as
necessary and there are alternatives
such as magnetic resonance imaging and
ultrasound that sometimes can be useful
and the decision about what to do of
course must be made by the health
professional involved in managing any
patient but most doctors in the
emergency room who order these CT scans
themselves according to a recent study
at Yale University which I site in my
book do not understand the risks and one
of the fastest growing segments of the
population with increased cancer are
people aged 20 to 40 there are now a
million cancer survivors under the age
of 40 Lance Armstrong is probably the
most famous of them he's not alone
as a testicular cancer survivor because
testicular cancer has almost doubled and
grow or grown fifty percent in every
industrial country whether or not
radiation plays a role for the increased
cancers in young people today I don't
know but I do know this if you had
Hodgkin's disease before age 16 and
received radiation to the chest your
Hodgkin's disease will be cured but by
the time you reach age forty one in
three women will have breast cancer one
in three will have breast cancer by the
time they reach age 40 if they've
received radiation to the chest before
age 16 for Hodgkin's disease because
Hodgkin's disease radiation therapy in
the past was much higher dose now the
good news is the radiation therapists
have figured out how to lower the dose
now for treating Hodgkin's disease but
in the past it clearly created problems
as a result of all of this the American
College of Radiology is recommending
that we licensed CT technologists and
test and train them and guess what we
don't now in my hospital at the
university of pittsburgh medical center
which actually covers many buildings and
in many states and several countries we
have state-of-the-art training of our
technologists as I'm sure most major new
york hospitals do but you've seen the
ads come get a whole body CT scan in a
shopping mall what certification and
standards and training is there there
and people are finding things i call
them imagine oma's they're finding
things particularly on the thyroid that
nobody knows what they mean we need a
national database of radiation doses we
need to improve training not only of the
technologists but of the pediatricians
and emergency medicine Doc's the
pediatric radiology community is warning
that we've got to stop ordering so many
unnecessary tests in children and adults
and the ironic thing is as you may know
you get fabulous quality images the
higher the dose of radiation you use
it's an extraordinarily beautiful
technique but we need to realize that it
may come as a Faustian bargain in some
circumstances now just to change the
mood a little bit I wanted to show you
Donald Rumsfeld now what does he have to
do with the war on cancer well it turns
out in 1977 the general counsel of the
FDA sought a grand jury indictment of
the GD searle company for submitting
fraudulent data on the safety of
aspartame the indictment never happened
I tell the details in my book in 1977
the same year the indictment is filed
the company hires Rumsfeld I don't think
he was hired for his expertise in
pharmacology but in 1981 the day after
Ronald Reagan was inaugurated the Searle
company filed for approval of aspartame
every single scientific group that had
ever reviewed the data on aspartame for
the FDA said no way this should be
approved there was no dissent 1981 it
was a new day remember the beginning of
the reagan revolution within five months
aspartame was approved now I want to
show you data that was just released
today how's this for topical i can put
this link on the websites as well bear
with me while I explain this aspartame
has been studied by the Rama Zini
foundation in Italy this is a
distinguished testing laboratory that
has been in existence for close to 30
years has tested many modern hazards and
this study looked at the age of death of
animals and they studied several
thousand rodents and they studied them
with prenatal exposure and postnatal
exposure some of the animals began to be
exposed
when they're rodent mothers were
pregnant and they measured at what age
the animals died and what amounts of
tumors occurred in the animals so you
see here in the postnatal exposure which
means the animals are exposed only after
birth but the animals were allowed to
live three years now those of you who do
toxicology understand that a typical
animal bioassay animals are sacrificed
at two years that would be killing
people at my age equivalent to 60 they
kill the animals if the animals are
allowed to live to the third year
they're approximating the lifetime that
most of you are going to reach in this
room which is your 80s and 90s and if
you do that you see here that the levels
of tumors that are found in the
prenatally exposed animals are up to
thirty percent of all of them will have
tumors compared to your control animals
this is your control animal here which
is ten percent and here you see the
difference in postnatal exposure you
have five percent tumors in the control
group and here you have fifteen percent
tumors let's translate that a little bit
okay prenatal aspartame exposure nearly
doubles the cancer rate in adult rodents
compared to postnatal exposure now what
about epidemiology after all we're not
rats well we're not but we are we differ
from them by a lot fewer genes than
people think perhaps 300 recent
epidemiologic studies have not found any
risk at all of cancer but let's talk
about those studies did they looked at
people aged 55 and did a survey and
asked them when they were 55 do you use
aspartame and then five years later they
said do you have brain cancer now I'm
not making this up this is what they
but you're snickering because you can
see how ridiculous this is we know that
brain cancer like many forms of cancer
can take 10 20 30 or 40 years to develop
it can so asking people whether they
used aspartame when they were 55 years
of age and seeing whether or not they
had brain cancer five years later isn't
really the most rigorous approach to the
question I would say the reality is
today more than 200 million people are
regularly consuming aspartame and let me
make sure you understand something about
the levels that were used here 2,000
parts per million is about five cans of
soda and maybe two yogurts with
aspartame a day okay that's not a lot of
aspartame and again the look here this
is really important for you to see that
if you killed these animals at two years
you wouldn't see necessarily a
statistically significant difference in
the amount of tumors here but when you
let the animals get out 23 years of life
which is where we all hope to get
equivalent to our 60s 70s 80s and 90s
then you see these incredible increases
in tumors and that's why I think it's
time to take another look at this
compound because if the US FDA were to
conclude that exposure to aspartame
causes cancer and rodents the agency
would have to revoke its approval well
now I want to turn to some of the good
news green is the new black the
University of Pittsburgh Medical Center
where I work is going green now we're a
very large institution you know those
ads you see in the New York Times we
cover a large area six states and I
think more than four countries and we
have more than 400 different buildings
we're going green that means we're
changing the way we clean the way we
operate the kinds of energy we use we're
changing our plastics to safer forms of
plastic and we're doing it
not because we know it's going to reduce
cancer but because we know it's going to
be more efficient and it's going to
reduce the probability or it's going to
reduce the chances the cancer and other
diseases will happen it's going to mean
that we're more responsible citizens to
our surrounding community NYU is
purchasing a hundred percent of its
energy from wind the world is going
green the fashion world green is the new
black in the business world in American
business as Tom Friedman is written
green is the new red white and blue and
ultimately it's going to mean less
cancer and more health for all of us now
I close with these polar bears because
they're beautiful but because they also
send us all a message the polar bears
are in trouble now you probably can
figure out that polar bears are not
really well designed to jump like white
men polar bears can't jump they've got
this huge rump and they're really not
very very I aerodynamic they're jumping
because they're trying to find ice to
hunt from in the Arctic summer and
they're not doing too well this is a
magnificent photo taken by Thomas D
mangelsen a friend of mine is a
world-renowned wildlife photographer
these polar bears are running out of ice
to hunt and they're fewer of them are
surviving now the other thing you may
not know about them is that one in a
hundred in the most recent survey is a
hermaphrodite with male and female
genitals and they are showing up with
carcinogens in their fat that would
qualify them for burial in a hazardous
waste site now how do these carcinogens
get into polar bears they don't work in
factories well you remember the the
movie The Lion King and there's this
scene where the the Lion King lead
characters depressed and the monkey says
to the parent
What's Eating him and the parrot says
nothing he's at the top of the food
chain the polar bear is at the top of
the food chain in the Arctic and at the
top of the human food chain is the
nursing infant so the polar bear is a
symbol of the global circulation of
pollutants and what's going on now is a
global phenomenon where the business
community understands whether its global
warming or toxic chemicals that policies
have to be addressed globally and
unfortunately the United States may lose
its competitive edge in chemicals
because of programs like the European
Union's reach program registration
evaluation and assessment of chemical
hazard which is stipulating that
chemicals must be proven to be safer
before they're put into products that
we're all exposed to in the book I talk
about one example of this a 14 dioxane
which causes cancer in male and female
rats and mice and is banned in Europe
and yet we allow it so my grandchildren
might be exposed to this chemical in
their shampoo and bubble bath but if
they were in Europe their bottoms would
not be endangered that doesn't make any
sense and I think people know that and
the american chemical industry
understands it so they're now asking for
more standards to be more uniform
because it's not going to help them if
we fail to meet the world standards with
respect to safety and chemicals now i
want to show you pittsburgh today this
is where we are this isn't these are all
real buildings they look almost like a
dream we have the world's largest green
Convention Center we have the world's
largest green greenhouse it has an earth
tube under it which goes down on the
ground and in the summer the air is
cooled by going through the ground and
in the winter the air is heated by going
down through the ground it is a net no
net energy it's self sufficient in the
green greenhouse we are one of the
Centers of green buildings our hospital
is going to be building a green
Children's Hospital
and we're leading the way to
understanding how we can do more with
less toxic materials for buildings and
for operations in medicine and in health
care sometimes people say to me you know
how you must be crazy if you think
you're going to do all of these things
and I think the answer is no you can't
do all of these things none of us can
but I take comfort from a message of a
rabbit our food which is a story in the
Talmud my modern variation of it goes
like this a group of workers are told
look you got to finish there's a job
here it's really big it's really
complicated and you got to do it and
they say what are you crazy we don't
have the right tools it's impossible and
we'll never get it done and the reply is
it's really not up to you to finish the
task but you must begin it thank you
right I'll be glad to take any questions
there's a microphone here I also want to
take a moment and introduce to people
Leon brad low is a hero of mine dr.
Bravo has done important work that I
think will lead us and to new frontiers
and we're hoping that our researchers at
the Center for Environmental ecology are
following in this where he has
identified metabolites of estrogen and
markers in the blood and urine that we
think will predict risk so we can
intervene and his work has been
phenomenal would you mind to Stanley on
so we can give you a round of applause I
want to thank you very much
all right Barbara semen is one of the
people we should have listened two years
ago in 1969 she first warned the
American audience about the dangers of
hormones for our health and it was only
of course when the US government
confirmed that Barbara seaman was right
that finally people began to act I want
to point out something though you know
breast cancer has started to fall down
fall a lot in an if in fact the decline
in breast cancer is associated women
stopping to use hormone replacement
therapy if it is that's good news for
all of us because it's saying that years
of exposure to a promoting agent like
hormones can reverse the harm if you
stop using the exposure what that means
for the rest of us is that ceasing
exposure to promoting agents to if you
went to epigenetic materials such as
have been documented on the recent Nova
documentary can be very valuable and
very important for us to do so I wish
we'd listened to Barbara seaman before
but now she's celebrated in the same
medical circles that used to blackball
her thank you right Barbara
thank you questions or comments and you
please identify yourself thank you Mark
no microphone I'm marshal a question
about asbestos and hormones what studies
have been done regarding the impact of
asbestos on you mentioned mezclas
messily Thelma has that definitely been
proven and and and how many cases have
there been that's number one and number
two as far as hormones which hormones in
regards to I guess the replacement
therapy have been shown to be dangerous
or disastrous and which ones have not
been if any all right well a
mesothelioma and it's its association
with a number of forms of of asbestos
has been very well established
unfortunately in the human literature
over over many years there's and I have
a lot of references in the book that can
provide information on that oh yes yes
many money many now with respect to
hormones i think i'll ask barbara to
tell us the latest there are some people
who believe that there's a difference
between bioidentical hormones and
synthetic hormones but there's really no
reason to think that's the case and the
studies have been done on on different
combinations of progesterone and
estrogen and their studies in England
which have found that even if you you
don't use combined hormone replacement
therapy you're still getting an
increased risk and the risk for hormone
replacement therapy is the following you
have a risk of breast cancer you have a
risk of deep vein thrombosis you have a
risk of blood clot you have a risk of
heart attack and there doesn't seem to
be any long protection even against
dementia which they thought there would
be so all of the things that hormone
replacement therapy was supposedly going
to protect you against at this point the
only one that there may be some evidence
for is bone loss but think about the
idea of this you're going to take a drug
starting in your 50
for the to prevent a disease namely
osteoporosis that typically affects
women in their 80s and so as a result
you're going to give yourself a risk of
chronic cancer to protect yourself
against the disease that may happen 30
years down the road and that's I think
one of the reasons why many of us were
concerned about this all along barber do
you want to add anything to this use the
microphone please you have to pull the
thing down to your right human is it on
louder there's an interesting situation
with the human female body and the
combinations of the hormones because if
you have estrogen and you add the
progestin to it it protects your uterus
and you're much less likely to get
anti-material cancer but it increases
your risk of having breast cancer so
it's as if you have to choose between
down lower up above and that's about
where we are now we we haven't gotten
far enough to do anything further but
I'd like to say that your book is really
to me the most important book on science
and health that I've seen in this
century that's for the last almost eight
years and it's a very engaging book it's
very hard to put it down except that at
times it's so disturbing that you put it
down and it's a great read and I think
in the end people will feel liberated
from it not not being terrified but
while you're radiant there are times
where we were terrified and I think
people should prepare for that and I'm
also very concerned for many years I was
blackballed because of my concern
about hormone products all told I was I
lost columns at five different women's
magazines when the advertisers moved in
and we're able to make a deal about as
and getting rid of my columns but I feel
that you covered so many things and so
deeply I mean I thought I knew all about
the studies on estrogen in the 1930s you
found another several times more that I
had never even found you have a way of
talking to people of looking at the
historic records at looking at the at
the epidemiologic findings I I think it
would be nice if you could tell us a
little more about how you managed to
bring all these things together but but
I am worried and I want to say to
everybody in the audience that you
deserve to be protected now I had i have
heard signs already of people who it's
called it's called a bringing doubt into
the question and that's a very
well-known way that that the people in
these commercial who are going to lose
money that's a very terrible way that
they're using it and i want to call
attention to a an article that was in
the scientific american called doubt
about two years ago it was by david
michaels who's also an empty or just he
happens to be my step-brother too but it
and he has a book coming out on this
topic of doubt and i think that anybody
who finds herself or himself being moved
honor or should they take Debra's of
finding seriously or to read this
material on how doubt works because that
will give you an underpinning and
staying the course with whatever is
telling us what you would think Thank
You Barbara
well I feel projected I've got my
husband here and and also it's a
different time I'm working for a
different place right now and as I say
in the book a lot more people who are
working on cancer themselves have cancer
and i think cancer is really not an
unusual political issue the republicans
and democrats all get cancer and I think
people understand now that we've got to
make some big changes so I'm hoping that
what my Bubbe used to tell me is still
true that when you have nothing to stand
on you can always stand on the truth and
I I admit there's things we don't know I
certainly know the epidemiology on many
of these things like aspartame the
epidemiology says there's no problem it
has absolutely nothing to do with what's
going to happen to children you know
today and and I hope your concerns are
not any more pertinent but I I know what
you went through and and we'll find out
at this point almost all the support for
my Center is coming from private
foundations headed by women by the way
and we're and we are supported through
major foundation grants though from
Teresa Heinz and the Heinz endowments in
the high mark Foundation and from
recently from the Winslow foundation
from Ren worth and others and we expect
to expand our purview to get that that
kind of support because i think it's
women who understand these issues first
and foremost and i think that there may
be a change in the government coming and
then things will look a little
differently for all of us thank you for
your concerns yes sir is there any good
good data on the instance of cancer
among chemists who are exposed on a
regular everyday basis to yes there are
there's excellent data showing that
chemists have an increased risk of the
number of forms of cancer women chemists
have an increased risk of breast cancer
men chemists have an increased risk of
lymphoma and leukemia and it's not
surprising because as dr. Bravo told me
if you trained in chemistry back in the
old days with mouth pipetting without
hoods without gloves
you were obviously exposed to to risks
and it's not surprising that those who
are still around who trained in the old
days in chemistry have encouraged some
risks from their work I haven't seen
that among many colors that I know and
yeah one would expect something like
that right well you know it's always
dangerous to talk about the people that
you know but but in fact in a study in
Shanghai found that women Chinese
chemists obviously had 14 times higher
rate of breast cancer compared to others
so there's there is a literature on it
and again I think the question of
Epidemiology has to always be framed as
part of a larger whole what is the
epidemiology tell us but what do we know
from the animal data and let's put it
all together rather than what we have
had done here in this administration
which is to say we don't have
epidemiologic evidence and as David
Michael's will say in his new book which
I'm looking forward to reading doubt is
manufactured the absence of evidence
becomes used like a cross held up to the
vampire we're uncertain we don't have
information so we better do nothing and
say nothing and I think that's the wrong
approach to take in the modern world so
thank you for your question yes ma'am um
I was wondering if you could tell me how
the recent stem cell research that's
been done over the last 10-15 years has
affected all the way we think about or
the premise of cancer therapeutics well
cancer therapeutics is really poised for
a revolution in immunology and
understanding of the process of cancer I
have a chapter in the book that explains
that the old approach to chemotherapy
came out of poison gas warfare poison
gas warfare it was fascinating little
story actually an astute army doc in the
First World War figured out that the
people who had survived poison gas
attacks had almost no white cells right
they had almost no white cells so he
figured out that people who had leukemia
who were full had too much white cell
they were called white blood was the
name VY split and leukemia was the Latin
translation from the German vice boot
white blood so he figured out that if
you could take the same agent that had
created no white blood cells in these
poison gas survivors and give it to
people who had leukemia maybe maybe you
could treat them and the first
treatments were in fact developed and
they were done as classified secret army
research during during World War two and
prior to it so the scientists who were
doing this work didn't even know what
materials they were injecting in people
and it was this classified use of poison
gas the new paradigm of cancer
therapeutics is totally different we are
no longer just killing the cancer we're
boosting the immune system we're taking
the body's natural defenses we're
finding agents in natural products like
the work that we're trying to do at our
center with broccoli extracts or things
from yogurt or garlic or fish oil or
chocolate or red wine a lot of
interesting things you can do there and
we're using these things to boost the
immune system to boost repair to enhance
the body's capacity to fix itself and
that I think is where the modern
paradigm has moved and is making you
know there really is a lot of progress
at the same time we have to make
progress at the other end which is
making fewer cases of cancer thank you
thank you for your talk you gave us in
various examples of business interests
averting the public interest and of
conflicted advocacy groups such as the
AMA in American Cancer Society can you
give us examples of the advocacy groups
that you see out there doing good work
raising these difficult issues and
quickly would you drink the diet coke
waiting us in the reception and you have
any thoughts about nuclear power in
terms of exposing people to cancers
products and whatnot thank you thank you
for such a simple question well first of
all the american cancer society today is
one of the most effective anti tobacco
groups in the world right so better late
than never and
they have done a great job on that issue
they need to do a better job on the
environment and they need to do a better
job in supporting basic research because
only one in ten dollars that they raise
actually supports independent basic
research most people don't know that the
American Cancer Society has done a lot
of good things when it comes to
publicizing cancer and getting
information out about the dangers of
smoking organizations that are doing a
better job today getting information to
people include the breast cancer fund
breast cancer action the environmental
working group that are documenting a
really broad array of things that need
to change you may not think that
agricultural policy affects cancer but
believe me it does and there are groups
out there understanding this issue you
may not think that climate policy or
energy policy affects cancer but believe
me it does in fact let me just show you
one example this is a proposed tower
that's going to be built cutting across
a swath of West Virginia Virginia
Maryland all right these towers are as
high as a 15 story office building what
is that got to do with cancer well in
order to fuel the energy the electricity
for those towers to run they're going to
have to beef up using dirty coal-fired
power plants that were supposed to be
mothballed until they got a new lease on
life under this administration and these
dirty coal-fired power plants release a
lot of pollutants which are direct
carcinogens and others that worsen the
environment so we have to start
recognizing that energy policy is really
public health policy as well now nuclear
power I think nuclear power is a great
idea I just wish it worked and what I
mean by that is the nuclear industry
does not have a good track record if
nuclear power could be made to be safe
and proven to be safe it would make a
lot of sense I'm concerned though that
the lifecycle costs of uranium mining of
building the power plants
operating them and the releases that
have occurred most recently in Japan
just last year create a record that
suggests it's going to be very difficult
for the nuclear power industry to live
up to the possibility of being the clean
form of energy that it could become
David oh sorry go ahead Brooklyn College
very nice talk thank you and I just had
a comment and then a question um the
comment was that the examples you've
cited for the chemicals and potential
cancer causes tend to be those sort of
chemicals that we all know about lead
dioxin things like that that are very
scary and one thing that you didn't
mention and that perhaps is in your book
are the chemicals that are now coming
into the environment through the use of
pharmaceuticals for example things that
get flushed down the toilet and we all
end up drinking and they get into the
environment and unlike things like
dachshund which are sort of perhaps week
estrogens we're talking about things
that are intentionally designed to be
estrogenic so just something I think to
be aware of and the the question
actually relates to the difference
between the medical community and the
public health community and can you
comment about how that have affected the
evolution of the the war on cancer and
whether maybe the medical community
community with its focus on a treatment
rather than prevention was a major
factor there Thanks well thank you this
very thoughtful question and let me say
that you're absolutely right the medical
approach necessarily looks at the
individual patient the individual organ
the individual disease the public health
approach necessary looks at the patterns
that individuals make a raid in time and
space and how their diseases might
reflect the different things they've
experienced throughout their lives and
that fundamental difference of focus is
in fact part of the legacy that we have
to deal with now with the war on cancer
the war on cancer starts as a medical
war with the germ theory of disease
which after all is premise Thanh the
notion that you find the germ and you
attack it pastors dying words are
relevant here pastor of course is
credited with having developed the germ
theory of disease with having understood
and that the pox was transmitted
infectiously from milk maids who were
immune to it but was transmitted to
others and that infectious transmission
was due to the germ okay he understood
the germ theory in fact the
varicella-zoster his dying words though
were remember the host remember the host
conditions and I think that is what's
going to lead to a new paradigm in
medicine today than many of my
colleagues in Pittsburgh are actually
adopting dr. Judy bulk dr. Mark Hyman
max Eisenberg at Harvard Freddie
Cronenberg at Columbia they're all
starting to ask let's not just treat the
disease let's find out what's in the
body of the person who has the disease
and we are hoping to develop quality
control tests for metal measuring metals
so that we can measure white cell counts
which we need to know and metal levels
and then understand what could be the
contribution of environmental factors to
someone's poor health along with the
things that we've traditionally looked
at but you're absolutely right the
medical model looks at individuals and
individual organs and diseases the
public health approach looks at the
patterns and it's combining those now
that will get us the best solution David
in a way you're already addressing what
I was going to ask that which was the
relation of cancer and infectious
disease and in a way in terms of public
policy for infectious disease of course
we want new antibiotics and someone is
ill you'd like to treat them as infected
but of course water purification and
wash your hands and things like that so
that I'm kind of interested in the
balance i suppose in and how you look at
the way that public policy and the way
medicine in terms of treating infectious
disease and how people are very
concerned about infectious disease
sometimes in the context of emerging
infections HIV so something very new or
biological terrorism's possibility and
it gives all of this sense of
environmental monitoring
and and yet there's also new emphasis on
trying to get new antiretrovirals let's
say or a renewed interest or or the
crossover that you didn't deal with when
you either mentioned pap smears and so
on that now with the HPV vaccines in
fact that it with an infectious disease
model which is something completely
different than the pollution model
you've been discussing but that also
gives rise to epidemic kind of
epidemiology the you know saws is a very
interesting complementary other idea so
I ask you just to contrast this
infectious disease model and the way
they're being considered not with with
cancer well I want to thank you for that
question about infectious diseases in
cancer and let me just say that in fact
some cancers may very well have a viral
etiology and human papillomavirus is not
just relevant to cervix cancer which we
know it is it's relevant to laryngeal
cancer as well it's relevant to anal
cancer and I'm going to read you a
little bit about the vaccine issue
scientists of now develop vaccines that
prevents the major forms of HPV
infection from taking root in the first
place trials have shown promising
results it was first tested on fewer
than 20,000 women between the ages of 15
and 25 it's being recommended and may be
required in pre teenage girls none of
whom was in this trial right despite the
lack a lack of experience with this
vaccine and young girls the CDC
recommends that 11 and 12 year old girls
be vaccinated against HPV much as they
are vaccinated against polio diphtheria
and typhoid but what about boys why are
we prepared to vaccinate young girls but
not young boys who can spread it there
actually are good reasons to think that
vaccinating boys would prevent anal
cancer in those they're gay and could
also reduce heterosexual transmission
from men to women might reduce the risk
of head and neck hpv-related cancers
groups are organized to protect the
purity of young girls and they are
incensed not surprisingly none of them
is
essing concerns about the health of gay
men or prospects for reducing laryngeal
cancer instead it's argued that
vaccinating against HPV will open the
door to wanton sexual behavior among
girls because among other things they
will need not to think about whether
they might contract cancer in 30 years
I've got news for them with two out of
every three girls having sex by age 18
and with close to half of them not
necessarily willing participants on each
occasion it makes little sense to
suppose the decisions about sexual
activity are based on the possibility of
getting cancer in middle age I am
concerned about the HPV vaccine because
it hasn't been fully tested and I want
to make I think that we often implement
programs in the United States without
looking at their long-term consequences
but you are right there is a clear
interesting interaction between
infectious diseases and cancer and it
made and there are certain viral
conditions that promote cancer
epstein-barr virus and aflatoxin
exposure in Africa are thought to
increase the expression of aflatoxin
related hepatocellular carcinoma and
habit and hepatitis B vaccine there's
now some trials in China using hepatitis
B vaccine to see we can reduce the
transmission of the pada cellular
carcinoma as well so I think that there
there's a lot of opportunity there for
fertile to make a pun exchanges but I
want to leave you with this thought from
kata poet of the nation I remember when
people rolled their eyeballs if you
suggested that opposition to abortion
was less about life than about sex
especially sex for women you have to
admit that thesis is looking pretty
solid these days no matter what the
consequences of sex pregnancy disease
and death abstinence for singles is the
only answer just as it's better for gays
to get AIDS than use condoms it's better
for women to get cancer than have sex
before marriage it
honor killing on the installment plan
one way of looking at the issue yes sir
I think we'll take this last question
would you comment on the effort to
rehabilitate DDT currently where they
are saying that the original testing was
flawed and DDT saves more people than
kills and things of that nature yeah
it's a sad day for all of us that the
science here has become so heavily
politicized and perverted I'm sorry it's
the last question I could have spend 40
minutes talking about it but let me just
say this in Mexico they eliminated
malaria without DDT by basic industrial
hygiene programs involving bed nets
eliminating the vectors in which malaria
can live which mosquitoes can breed
namely standing still water they did
that in Mexico with rural workers
following advice from the government and
the person who ran that program is a
dear colleague and friend of mine who is
currently a very senior member of the
Mexican government he was brought into
the United States Institute of Medicine
to present what he done he thought but
they didn't want to hear about it
because he came back and he said to me
the deck is stacked here they're going
to reapproved EDT I said oh my god I
can't believe that because here's what
we know about DDT DDT is associated with
low birth weight babies according to
research done by the National Institutes
of Environmental Health Sciences DDT
kills adult mosquitoes it does not kill
the larvae it kills the adult mosquitoes
if you have an epidemic of a lethal
mosquito-borne disease like dengue or
yellow fever or equina encephalitis
where fifty percent of the people who
get it will die you might need to use
DDT as an emergency but the idea that
you should be spraying it as they will
inside homes in Africa now in Kenya I
think is a very very bad idea we have
seen over and over again that when you
use DDT to treat mosquitoes and try to
prevent malaria you create resistance to
the DDT we know that DDT
has profound effects on hormones it may
be an anti-androgen it makes it works
through very many different ways the
best solutions for malaria involve
keeping people out of the areas where
the mosquitoes are and using basic in
hygiene methods with bed nets and
removing standing in Stillwater I'm
concerned about the widespread proposals
to reintroduce DDT and I'm not alone in
those concerns but I recognize that
there may be some circumstances under
which you have to use DDT or other
pesticides but they should be much more
limited than what is being proposed
right now I'm very concerned about it so
I think at this point we'll have time
for a reception and i want to thank you
for your questions